bonjour pierre laurin merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on a
entendu il ya quelques secondes
vladimir poutine qui parle de pressions
extérieures sans précédent est ce que le
président russe vise ici la visite d'
emmanuel macron dans les pays baltes je
pense qu'il vise un ensemble
d'événements pas seulement la visite d'
emmanuel macron mais également les
différentes mises en garde de l'union
européenne
les discussions au sein de l'union
européenne sur les sanctions ou pas
sanctions avec finalement à sanction
mais parce que certains pays notamment
chypre ont mis leur veto mais également
à l'activité d'un certain nombre de
groupes américains et européens qui
pousse depuis relativement longtemps et
pas seulement en biélorussie le vert les
changements de régime ça a été le cas
notamment en serbie en 99 en géorgie en
2003 en ukraine en 2004 en biélorussie
une première fois en 2005 et maintenant
encore en biélorussie
alors est-ce que emmanuel macron affirme
que la paix en europe ne pourra jamais
se faire sans la russie
peut-il être à la fois opposé à
loukachenko et allié de la russie
ah c'est très difficile je crois que les
circonstances
aujourd'hui sont très défavorables pour
le plan des manuels macron qui est de
tisser des liens avec la russie
d'intégrer la russie dans l'ensemble
européen
la russie fait partie de leurs
indiscutablement mais il ya une barrière
et la barrière c'est évidemment les
problèmes politiques
actuellement il y à deux crises majeures
la crise biélorusse mais également le
problème de l'empoisonnement supposée
dans l'excellent navalni et il la
plupart des partenaires européens
de la france vise dénonce la russie
comme étant ou du moins le pouvoir russe
comme étant l'instigateur de la sphère
navalni mais également des problèmes en
biélorussie et de ce fait
emmanuel macron n'a pas d'autre solution
que d'emboîter le pas au consensus
européen
il n'a pas suffisamment de latitude pour
se singulariser
mais ils essayent tout de même de lancer
le message de poursuivre le message il
faut négocier avec la russie
il faut traiter avec la russie est juste
c'est très grand vous parler de ses
négociations avec la russie un emmanuel
macron a confirmé qu'à la demande de
l'europe l'organisation pour la sécurité
et la coopération en europe allait
tenter une médiation en accord avec la
russie on imagine que tout le monde
pourra éventuellement travailler
ensemble effectivement c'est l'une des
pistes de travail ensemble mais pour
résoudre le problème biélorusse je crois
que il faut simplement donner un peu de
temps au temps
parce que la position de loukachenko à
l'intérieur est relativement faible
il est évident qu'aujourd'hui ni la
biélorussie ni la russie ne peuvent se
permettre le départ de loukachenko parce
que ce serait la mort ce de ce que
craignent le plus les russes c'est à
dire une révolution de couleur en
biélorussie en revanche une entente
entre le pouvoir actuel et l'opposition
et qui n'est pas hostile à des
négociations internes interne de cet
ordre sous l'égide de la russie aurait
des chances de de réussir à partir du
moment où le projet de révision de la
constitution qu'a avancé lukashenko
avance et aboutit à quelque chose à une
solution de transition qui permettrait à
loukachenko de sauver la face et à
l'opposition de jouer un rôle plus
important dans la politique ukrainienne
vous parliez à l'instant de l'opposition
justement emmanuel macron a rencontré
est la figure de l'opposition à
biélorusse ce matin à cette lan à tirana
sky a est ce que elle elle a confirmé un
veto d'arnaud sky à avoir répondu
favorablement à une invitation pour
s'exprimer devant l'assemblée nationale
est ce que l a besoin fondamentalement
du soutien de la france
je crois qu'elle a besoin de tous les
soutiens possibles maintenant terrano
sky1 n'est pas la seule opposante
il y à l'opposition interne elle elle
est à l'extérieur c'est à dire que sa
marge de manoeuvre dépend de la bonne
volonté des pays baltes et de leurs
alliés européens haussent en duo sein de
l'union européenne en particulier mais
pas seulement
en revanche à l'intérieur il y a une
autre branche de l'opposition qui est
dirigé par collins callas ou bien la
prix nobel de littérature alexievitch
qui est beaucoup plus neutre dans la
mesure où cette branche la sent bien que
sans la russie
il est difficile de trouver une solution
parce que jamais les occidentaux les
alliés occidentaux de tifra north callas
ne vont imposer d'une manière ou d'une
autre
diplomatiquement ou éventuellement par
la force ce qui est exclu un pouvoir
autre que celui de loukachenko
la seule solution c'est la négociation
et je pense que l'opposition interne est
beaucoup plus à même de réussir cette
solution diplomatique que l'opposition
externe
qui par nature est un tag ou mystique il
est évident que son nez dans un rapport
de force et le rapport de force
actuellement menée pas favorable à
l'union européenne
merci beaucoup pierre laurin d'avoir été
avec nous à ce matin sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
écrivain et auteur de l'ukraine et
histoire entre deux destins merci
beaucoup